[Música]
tomémonos un momento para mirar a las
personas que están a su lado
a su izquierda y a su derecha
si es la primera vez que ven a una de
esas personas
estarían ustedes dispuestos a
entregarles su teléfono celular durante
los próximos 15 minutos
confiaría en esa persona que acaban de
conocer
la confianza es un elemento fundamental
para el funcionamiento de las sociedades
pero no solamente para las sociedades es
fundamental para tu relación con tu
pareja
para la relación con tu equipo de
trabajo
pero también con desconocidos por
ejemplo cuando vas en la vida y ves que
el semáforo está en verde y confías que
los conductores de la otra vía no van a
pasar
pero también confías en que los
servicios del gobierno a cargo de los
semáforos funcionan
y que no van a poner la luz de en verde
para los dos
pero parece haber un problema
que la verdad me preocupa que no mucha
gente lo ve
y que si no se soluciona o no se
revierte puede generar problemas para la
sociedad
me refiero a la baja confianza entre
personas y a la disminución de la
confianza en las instituciones
lo que ustedes ven allí en color azul
países como australia china suecia son
países donde más del 40% de las personas
dicen que se puede confiar en otros lo
que está en grises porque no tiene datos
pero lo que no está ni en azul ni en
gris es donde menos del 40% de la
población dice que se puede confiar en
otros
como ven esto es un problema de gran
parte del mundo y en el caso de colombia
estamos por debajo del 10%
menos del 10 por ciento de los
colombianos pensamos que se puede
confiar en otro
y eso que nos afecta
pues el profesor paul zak demostró en
que los países con mayores niveles de
confianza son más prósperos
económicamente
y que los países con menos niveles de
confianza son más pobres y por qué
porque si queremos hacer negocios o
acuerdos como los hacemos todos los días
en países con menores niveles de
confianza vamos a tener que ir a
intermediarios como abogados o jueces
para que nos ayuden a garantizar que
esos acuerdos se cumplan
mientras que en los países donde hay
mayores niveles de confianza no los
consultan tanto y esos son costos
adicionales pero como no los consultan
tanto también tienen más tiempo para
hacer más negocios
muchas veces esos intermediarios también
fallan ofrecen malos servicios o se
corrompen y entonces tenemos una
combinación donde no solamente hay una
un bajo nivel de confianza en las
personas sino que también hay una
disminución de la confianza en las
instituciones
por ejemplo este es el nivel de
confianza en el gobierno de los eeuu
durante los últimos 60 años
como vemos pasa del 80% a un 20%
y no solamente pasa en eeuu salvo
algunas excepciones de países esto es la
constante
la pregunta que tenemos que hacernos es
qué pasa con la sociedad si esas
tendencias siguen bajando
pero más importante aún que podríamos
hacer para revertir esa tendencia
desde la universidad nacional de
colombia y desde el centro para la
cuarta revolución industrial
hemos venido investigando como
tecnologías de la cuarta revolución
industrial podrían ayudar a generar
mayor confianza en los servicios que
recibimos del gobierno y particularmente
yo he estado investigando con un equipo
con dos equipos de los cuales me siento
muy orgulloso sobre una tecnología que
se llama blocks o cadena de bloques en
español
y blocks en si queremos entender la de
una manera sencilla tenemos que
imaginarnos que si tenemos un computador
que está conectada a blocks en toda la
información que registremos en ese
computador
se réplica de manera casi instantánea en
miles de computadores a nivel global
y se hace a través de bloques de
información que van conectados unos con
otros por eso su nombre de cadena de
bloques
y si quisiéramos modificar información
que ya está registrada en blogs ya
tendríamos que modificar al menos la
mitad más uno de los miles de
computadores donde ya está registrada
esa información y tendríamos que
hacerlos al mismo tiempo poniendo una
gran cantidad de energía y de capacidad
de cómputo lo que lo hace no solamente
muy complicado de hacer sino también muy
costoso
entonces podemos decir y podemos confiar
que lo que registremos en blogs ya no va
a poder ser eliminado
hay una frase que lo resume bastante
bien o que lo representa bastante bien
la ley en un artículo que dice que
bloquen es como las vegas
lo que pasa en bloque no se queda en
bloque
y cuando estaba preparando esta charla y
pensando cómo explicar el funcionamiento
de blocks y me acordé de la primera vez
que escuché hablar de esta tecnología y
porque me apasiona y me engancho y fue
una casualidad porque en el mismo día
recibí dos invitaciones a dos eventos
una de un primo y otra de un grupo de
tecnología en whatsapp donde invitaban a
conocer sobre esta tecnología de bitcoin
y blogging
cuando fui al primer evento tuve la
fortuna de que los conferencistas eran
muy buenos y que yo tenía la ventaja de
llevar varios años en tecnología
y la verdad es que no entendí nada
pero tenía el segundo evento
en la noche asistí y quede igual de
confundido
pero lo que me pareció interesante es
que vive unos programadores
desarrolladores de software que estaban
hablando de cómo crear y transferir
dinero sin necesidad de intermediarios
sin necesidades de bancos centrales ni
bancos comerciales es más esta
tecnología
bitcoin parecía que no encontraba
ninguna barrera en las fronteras
nacionales
y lo más sorprendente es que funcionaba
era solo código pero solo un protocolo
pero funcionaba y lo ha hecho durante
los últimos 11 años desde la primera vez
que se empezó a minar bloques de bits
y luego de esas dos conferencias me
quedaron como pueden ver más preguntas
que respuestas y una de esas fue si se
podía utilizar esta tecnología para
sectores diferentes al financiero
y encontrar que bloquen tiene unas
cualidades que la hacen muy interesante
para servicios del gobierno
y aquí les quiero hacer una pregunta por
favor alza la mano quien confía 100 en
las votaciones
100 en las votaciones
como ven tenemos un problema de
confianza
y en ese sentido con la alcaldía mayor
de bogotá realizamos un piloto en tres
colegios públicos distritales donde los
niños seleccionaron a sus líderes
estudiantiles en un proceso asegurado
con block sing
ustedes pueden ver los niños simplemente
se identificaban y veían las fotos de
sus candidatos y clicka van y detrás el
sistema hacia toda esa réplica y
aseguraba el voto de la manera que se
los explique aprovechamos por supuesto
como ellos no veían allí que pasaba
detrás en y como se aseguraba
aprovechamos para hacer formación con
los estudiantes y con los profesores y
los directivos nos decían que con estas
votaciones era mucho más rápido el
proceso y cuando tenían papel que ahora
ya no lo tienen que utilizar ya pesar de
que era una simple prueba todavía estos
colegios le piden el servicio a la
alcaldía
pero en votaciones no es el único
servicio de gobierno donde hay falta de
confianza
históricamente funcionarios se han
puesto de acuerdo para cambiar registros
y derechos de propiedad de tierras
y por esa razón muchas personas han
perdido sus propiedades
con la agencia nacional de tierras
desarrollamos un piloto donde aseguramos
todo el proceso de restitución de
tierras los registros de los campesinos
del predio y del proceso judicial que le
da derechos y además los funcionarios
que querían ingresar información o que
ingresaban la información del proceso
además de su usuario y contraseña
tenían que hacer reconocimiento facial
esto lo que buscaba es generar o buscar
que estas cualidades de blogs en de
seguridad y transparencia pudieran
transmitir en nosotros los ciudadanos
una mayor confianza en el proceso
pero no es el único caso donde la
seguridad y la transparencia nos podrían
ayudar a generar confianza en servicios
de gobierno
por ejemplo la corrupción
cerca del 2% del producto interno bruto
del mundo se pierde por corrupción en el
caso de colombia estamos hablando de más
del 5 por ciento y según estudios de la
ocde el 57 por ciento de esos casos se
da por sobornos a funcionarios en
procesos de contrataciones públicas
es por eso que con la procuraduría
general de la nación y curiosamente esta
mañana en el avión viniendo para
barranquilla nos saludamos con el
procurador estamos trabajando en un
proyecto
para registrar todo un proceso de
licitación del programa de alimentación
escolar que se han escuchado
han montado carteles para robarse la
plata de la comida de nuestros niños y
que desde los borradores hasta la
selección del proponente el proceso esté
asegurado con bloque y que podamos ir
registrando ir mirando todas las
propuestas de las empresas y hay una
evaluación automática
pero más importante en este proyecto es
que se va a habilitar y se va a buscar
que todos ustedes los ciudadanos
periodistas universidades puedan
ayudarnos a ingresar en esa plataforma
donde la información que está registrada
no se puede modificar
nos ayuden a identificar posibles focos
de corrupción y que si encuentran y
tienen alguna prueba en la plataforma lo
denuncien se genera una alerta a la
procuraduría general de la nación que
abriría una investigación estas estas
denuncias por supuesto serían de manera
anónima y esto es lo que podría
incentivar es que empresas que deciden
no presentarse a procesos de licitación
empiecen a hacerlo ahora y que haya más
proponentes y que haya más competencia y
que nosotros como ciudadanos podamos ver
mejores soluciones a mejores precios
para quienes quieren acompañarnos en
este fascinante mundo de la tecnología
blocks en este alguna buena noticia hay
una gran oportunidad esta tecnología es
muy joven la fase 11 años con bitcoin
pero las aplicaciones más allá de los
temas financieros no tienen más de cinco
años
es decir estamos a cinco años de la
punta
yo personalmente me levanto a trabajar
todos los días pensando que podemos
tener unos servicios de gobierno que se
vean reflejados en una mejora de calidad
de vida y que podamos pagar nuestros
impuestos con gusto y que los líderes se
ganen nuestra confianza cada día pero
block chen no es una panacea ni nos va a
solucionar todos los problemas pero sí
puede ser una herramienta muy poderosa
que nos dé participación pero también
responsabilidad para ser parte de la
solución
el compromiso tiene que nacer de cada
uno
pero si lo hacemos juntos yo confío es
más estoy seguro que si lo hacemos
juntos vamos a hacer un mejor país
muchísimas gracias